she's over 100 years old you know God
knows where it's been what it's seen
this is just a little bit bigger yeah
because I think we are apples are too
big this has too many too many layers
this is you know it's supposed to be a
square corner I mean there's rounded
corners on these things
it's the ammunition 150 grain projectile
travels over 2,600 feet per second they
would just put their eyeball on it here
line this up with the backstop and then
anything between the end of the muzzle
and the backstop that's on that line
that trajectory gets shot we have to
make right now a sort of critical
decision which is do we shoot the bullet
on the right you see there's some groove
markings on that bullet hold those
grooves are created as the bullet rifles
out of the barrel he can tell the
direction the bullet is traveling and
rotating in fact the setup had to be in
that direction otherwise the bullet
would be rotating in the wrong direction
it doesn't come out of that barrel
spiraling this way it comes out
spiraling at least do you want to
recreate the image he printed or do you
want to recreate the negative he shot
and then do the reversal let's shoot
look at us he shot it we need to flip
the cue levy if he said the negative we
shot the other way
so we're gonna do now is take one
test-fire of the rifle and because we
can't really see that well through the
three mil thick polyethylene sheeting
that is our cube over there what we're
gonna do is punch a hole in both sides
using the bullet and it'll give us the
trajectory of the bullet and we can
string a string from the entrance hold
of the exit hole and on that line we can
place the app got it thank you
the shell here and the shadow of the
shell are not perfectly parallel and
this side of the Apple is the the
backsplash here is pretty close but it's
also higher than the stuff coming out of
this salt which means backdrop has to be
tilted no I was gonna be here yeah yeah
well we know bullets in here that is
right the next step is set up the strobe
so this is what's known as a piezo
electric trigger now the cool thing is
that the bullets flying along at
supersonic velocity and because it's
supersonic it has a sonic boom a shock
wave that travels with the bullet in
this case that sonic boom is gonna rate
back at a rather sharp angle but when
the sonic boom hits the mic but you fire
the stroke five is put in Apple
like top plays you know at some point we
run out of apples at some point we get
the backdrop so clocked up
fire I thought we flew here